public sénat et le centre national du
livre présente livres et vous
[Musique]
bonjour et bienvenue dans livres et vous
votre nouvelle émission littéraire qui
par des livres pour aller vers vous
chaque semaine je vous retrouve dans l'
annexe de la bibliothèque du sénat pour
accueillir des personnes qui font vivre
la littérature ce qu'ils écrivent bien
sûr mais aussi ceux qui la lisent ou qui
sont inspire pour agir et créer
autrement
aujourd'hui je vous propose une
rencontre entre l'écrivain tahar
bendjelloun auteur d'une vingtaine de
romans et de récits et reçu le prix
goncourt en 1987 pour la nuit sacrée et
qui fait paraître chez gallimard
la punition dans lequel il raconte son
enfermement dans un camp militaire sous
le règne d'hassan ii alors qu'il avait
20 ans le rejoindra en deuxième partie
l'avocat richard malka qui continuaient
pas au tribunal est l'auteur de bandes
dessinées souvent dystopique et
récemment d'un roman qui décrit les
affres pervers et romanesque de la
tyrannie
le roman s'appelle tyrannie bonjour
tahar benjelloun bonjour d'elle
bienvenue dans livres et vous ben je
suis ravi d'être là dans cette pub
magnifique on entouré d'amis qui sont
silencieux mais peuvent parler à
n'importe quel moment vous pensez qu'ils
sont silencieux bas ils sont sages mais
dès qu'on les touche qui s'ouvre et
voilà on est ailleurs sur rue d'ham
l'écrivain de la lumière ça vous va
comme appellation ce sublime si je
pouvais l'être vraiment pas j'essaie de
l'être jeudi j'essaie d'aller vers la
lumière c'est un peu mon chemin
parce que ce que j'écris n'est pas
toujours très gai mais j'essaie un petit
peu de capter cette lumière qui ont
chacun de nous et qui qui fait la vertu
de l'humanité
le thème de la lumière est très présent
dans votre oeuvre dans vos différents
romans et récits et on le trouve aussi
dans le titre d'une exposition on
pouvait voir vos peintures car vous êtes
peintre également jusqu'en janvier
dernier à l'institut du monde arabe
l'exposition s'appelait j'essaie de
peindre la lumière du monde
oui parce que j'ai avant j'ai jugé
j'écris sur la douleur du monde et la
jeune femme parce que dans la vie il
n'ya pas que le malheur il ya aussi
l'autre fasse ce que j'appelle la
lumière le bonheur la danse la joie la
fête
le nom envie d'être vivant et c'est ce
que j'ai essayé de faire dans ses
peintures et qui est un petit peu
l'autre versant de ma vie d'écrivain une
chose étonnante à votre sujet c'est que
vous ne connaissez pas votre date de
naissance savez pas si vous êtes né en
1944 en 1947
je pense que ces 47 par déduction parce
que mon père m'avait vieilli pour entrer
à l'école en même temps comment ferait
qu il ya des zones plus que moi donc on
a fait tout ce qui a été ensemble et à
l'époque mon père ne voulait pas que je
reste à l'école coranique où j'ai été
maltraité un jour par le fqih enfin le
maître d'école donc ils m'avaient
vieilli mais à l'époque on avait pas
d'état civil au maroc dans les années
40-50 est bon mais je fasse toujours
vécu avec une date à pied approximatif
skip hamas qui est un petit peu puis ya
peu on est dans le l'illusion mais peu
importe on a l'âge de ses convictions
l'âge de ces sa volonté de son ambition
et vous d'été différemment les
événements de votre vie en fonction de
ce qui vous est arrivé des livres qui
sont publiés dans votre dernier livre la
punition vous raconter comment vous avez
été enfermé dans un camp militaire après
avoir participé à des manifestations
vous aviez alors une vingtaine d'années
j'avais 20 ans et 20 ans rue 19 20 ans
oui et c'était pas n'était pas
officiellement un enfermement c'est un
service militaire qui cite les
transformer en un service de
redressement disciplinaire il fallait il
fallait que c'est que ces étudiants
turbulents opposants au régime grâce n 2
soit puni parce qu'ils ont osé contester
le système surtout de l'éducation
nationale donc on était 94 quand elle va
d'ailleurs y avait avec nous à ne se
quittaient pas étudiants quittaient pas
militant ni rien mais qui était un
ingénieur agronome et qui ont moins de
40 ans et qui avait refusé un poste que
vous avez osé désobéir au roi on avait
envoyé avec nous pour être punis
il restait deux ou trois mois après les
rapporte il a été libéré vous à pied ce
roman la punition parce que vous
racontez cette finition mais aussi dit
vouer cette phrase est très forte vous
dites mal que la vraie punition ça a été
deux mètres cinquante ans avant de
pouvoir écrire ce qui s'était passé
depuis vous avez écrit une vingtaine de
lady d au moins de réussite mais vous
n'aviez jamais raconté cet événement qui
viendra où il faudra pas bribes comme ça
mais comme j'ai beaucoup de séquelles de
cette période notamment l'insomnie le
fait que je mange vite le fait que des
inquiétudes et angoisse inexpliqué j'ai
voulu raconter ça pour me libérer de
tout ça je me fallait beaucoup de temps
pour le faire
mais quand je les fais quand j'ai
commencé à le faire ce qui est
extraordinaire ma mémoire est
extraordinaire vraiment est arrivée elle
met en forme et surtout je retrouvais
les odeurs nous et à prendre je
retrouvais les couleurs les noms des
gens les matins blêmes les nuits
interminables toutes arrivées en même
temps ma maman m'a communiqué qui
écrivait à ma place presque
et pourquoi avoir mis tant de temps à
écrire ces moments fondateurs vous dit
que c'est peut-être grâce à cet
événement que vous êtes devenu écrivain
c'est tellement grâce à ses 19 mois dans
cette espèce de d'absence de liberté et
de ré et du dignité parce qu'on n'était
pas respectée dans notre dignité d'être
humain et j'écrivais en cachette des
petits poèmes en même temps j'en voyais
des petits pois fonds envoyés j'écrivais
des poèmes pour la fiancée qui allait me
trahir donc j'ai passé un mauvais moment
kw à 7 ans n'étaient pas le plus beau le
plus bel âge de la vie pour moi à
l'époque et j'aimais beaucoup de temps à
revenir là dessus parce que je me dis
qu'est l'intérêt de raconter cet épisode
est en fait c'est en voyant le maroc
d'aujourd'hui qui a énormément changé
sous l'impulsion du roi même si ce
qu'est vraiment moderniser le pays et
qui lui a redonné sa place sa dignité
que je me suis dit il faut que je
raconte ça pour que les jeunes
aujourd'hui sache qu'elle était
ce maroc là parce que les hommes
politiques n'écrivent pas sur le maroc
le maroc hassan ii ou oui personne écrit
sur cette période
or moi je vais vous raconter ma période
à moi mon petit ma petite expérience est
comme ça les jeunes d'aujourd'hui vont
en lisant ce qu'en lisant elle va avoir
au moins un aperçu sur ce qu'est ce qu'a
été ce maroc avant l'arrivée de m6 et
s'éteint c'est un texte qui diffère de
vos précédents textes par le style et la
forme c'est une écriture presque au jour
le jour
on est dans la tête de votre personnage
vous quand vous aviez une vingtaine
d'années et il ya quelque chose de très
haletant il ya aucun effet de style
parfois dans vos récits vous avez vous
il ya de la poésie une formule 1 c'est
que c'est une écriture sèche sans
adjectif presque à un rapport rapport
mais en même temps il ya derrière la
salle je pense qu'il ya une poésie de
poésie de désespoir quelques mots un peu
mais c'est un texte est vrai que je sais
c'est le sujet qui est un qui impose le
style c'est pas on va pas les tiens je
vais écrire un livre avec une écriture
sèche non tu en écrivant que ça vient et
d'ailleurs après la votre libération de
ce qu'on vous alors vous faites des
études de philosophie et vous écrivez en
effet le mali sans dufilho donc j'ai
tous étaient interrompues et j'ai
terminé juste sorti en janvier 68 et
j'ai passé ma ma dernière partie la
licence de philosophie en juin 68 et
j'étais en octobre 68
désigné prof de philo à tétouan et vous
écrivait à ce moment là aussi votre
premier poème c'est la poésie la forme
qui s'impose c'est là que j'ai écrit
dans le camp en sortant j'ai rassemblé
tout ça j'ai mis un peu en forme et je
voulais arriver la poésie danko mais en
mieux en cachette
bien sûr et s'étaient imposés quitté
pick-up hermétique exprès parce que je
voulais pas que que l'adjudant du coin
ou le commandant tombe dessus que le
tabasse donc cgt j'étais un petit peu
dans un style malabar et j'ai déjà les
verts les choses un peu plus obscurs
mais je disais beaucoup de choses puis
les histoires la haine de la répression
le besoin de liberté mais mais c'était
toujours métaphorique que tu toujours
très très loin d'eux s'était pas direct
et pas j'étais pas comme ça a donné ce
n'était pas une poésie d'une violence
directe elle n'était plus plus subtile
et vous devenez ensuite vous allez à
part et vous devenez journaliste nicolas
beau journaliste eu la chance de tomber
sur des un formidable qui m'ont
accueillie j'ai été très bien accueilli
et mon 71 dans ce pays dont la france
m'a ouvert les bras devant ta stick et
j'ai commencé à faire des piges pour le
monde le monde des livres
d'abord il pue le monde de demain y
avait un supplément le samedi qui dit me
dirigée par pierre viansson-ponté qui
était le prince des journalistes
français c'est un grand monsieur qui m'a
beaucoup aidé et qui m'avait dit vous
êtes chez vous m'envoyer un paquet par
semaine j'écris jusqu'à sa mort on se
sent 18
après c'est plus difficile d'être un
type d'écriture qui est très différent l
écriture journalistes et j'ai appris à
l'enregistrement j'ai appris à écrire
journalistique mans tout en gardant
l'aspect littéraire et à partir du
moment où jacques fauvet commencé à
m'envoyer
dans des pays pour faire des reportages
je me jettent et contraint d'écrire dans
un style journalistique mais tout un tas
de littéraires c'est une période
magnifique qui ne coupent et moi ce
genre d'écriture a disparu aujourd'hui
aujourd'hui les importations très bref
très très percutant tout ça moi je
prenais le temps je faisais une série de
trois papiers qui partent commencé lundi
stimulée mercredi dans aujourd'hui non
c'est autre chose le réalisme a beaucoup
changé et ce jour n'a particulièrement a
beaucoup changé et avant de revenir
vraiment à l'écriture de romans vous
connaît aujourd'hui pour les romans vous
avez écrit mais vous avez fait beaucoup
d'autres de choses avant vous soutenez
une thèse alors est pas en philosophie
mais en psychiatrie sociale sur les
problèmes différents suel c'est les
travailleurs noirs africains en france
mais parce que c'est très simple je
travaillais à l'époque j'étais très
intéressé par la psychanalyse la
psychiatrique et je travaillais sur le
complexe d'oedipe
j'essaie de démontrer qu'ils n'étaient
pas universelle et je travaille sur
justement les populations africaines et
là dessus
quelqu'un m'a mais dit il ya monsieur
chertok le professeur chertok qui était
le grand spécialiste de l'hypnose en
france qui cherche quelqu'un pour
l'aider
je suis allé le voir il me dit j'ai des
arabes ici je comprends pas ce qu'ils
disent j'avais besoin d'un interprète
maintenant j'ai besoin de quelqu'un qui
parle avec eux et me voilà bombardé
psychothérapeute sauvage de parole
alors je recevais tous les mercredis des
patients s'étaient dès la plupart des
immigrés noirs africains qui venait
consulter pour le problème de puissance
sexuelle et c'était très curieux parce
que je laissais parlé et je voyais qu'il
voulait traumatisme énorme chez ces
hommes là parce que c'était avant la
vole le regroupement familial
c'était uniquement des hommes
célibataires qui tu es là et qu'ils
avaient des problèmes énormes qui avait
la culpabilité quand j'allais chez les
prostituées qui avaient enfin bref et
j'ai passé trois ans à faire ça et ça a
été ma thèse de doctorat que j'ai
soutenu à 75 en présence entre autres de
jean genet qui te dans la salle qui a
tenu à assister à sa soutenance
vous connaissez bien changé naroui
c'était une amitié très très spécial
parce que c'est lui qui choisit ses amis
et c'est lui qui choisissait content
d'aller se voir et quand tout ça parce
que je vais téléphoner dire à la
quantité les faux neige il fallait se
libérer toute la journée parce que c'est
x est quelqu'un d'absolument
extraordinaire
et qu'est ce qui fait qu'après ces
différents travaux de la poésie que vous
écrivez quand vous êtes dans le camp de
l'exercice journalistique la thèse que
vous décidez de produire un récit de
votre premier roman qu'est ce qui vous
fait basculer dans la littérature parce
que je voulais raconter des histoires en
poésie on peut pas tellement raconté on
peut évoquer les choses mais raconter
mais j'ai fait un conteur j'adore
raconter l'histoire j'ai avant tout le
temps des histoires et alors j'ai
commencé commencé comme ça et ça fait
mon premier roman et je me souviens
j'avais travaillé deux ans dessus arruda
je les portais à maurice nadeau
parce que maurice ados venus de publier
deux auteurs maghrébins j'étais
peut-être qu'ils aiment ça et j'arrive
chez lui et il me dit elle était très
beau grand et est pas très communicatif
et médias on va voir ça vous écrira un
mois après jenson il est passé nous voir
et pour le roman et je vais publier ça à
bon et me dire moins aimé dit cette
phrase on boit vous n'allez pas me donne
du travail
c'est pourquoi ça veut dire qu'il ya
rien à faire sur le texte est impeccable
et un bon tu très bien c'était passé
comme ça et après et après vous avez
écrit là pour le coup de nombreux romans
on trouve des thèmes qui les traversent
tout ça que ce soit une forme de dualité
dans la langue
peut-être entre le français le marocain
il est beaucoup question aussi de sexe
de pouvoir de bisexualité leur nom qui
vous fait connaître et qui va avoir le
prix goncourt c'est la nuit sacrée qui
la suite de l'enfance à leurs hôtes
somme qui raconte l'histoire d'une
fratrie de huit filles pour la 8ème et
bien le ses parents refusent que ce soit
une femme dont il dessine le p6 elle va
devenir un garçon elle s'appelle ahmed
et l'histoire d'ahmed est fantastique
elle va notamment épousé une fille
délaissée comme pour se venger d'un
certain statut qu'on lui a imposée alors
évidemment quand on lit les willy lui un
texte terrible parce qu'il ya des scènes
de ce genre
iain des choix que les milliers nuit
c'est le livre
érotique ou pornographique tout atelier
parce que les gens vont et s'est
précipité dessus temps bien non mais je
dire ils vont chercher ça mais il il dit
un peu toute la complexité de la
sexualité humaine est en fait lorsque
ahmed a épousé enfin sont bons du point
mais c'est une fille ou un garçon
vincent blonde épouse et une autre fille
pour lui venir en aide
enfin tout ça ça laisse présager
beaucoup de complexité beaucoup de
chemin dans cette sexualité qui n'est
pas aussi simple que ça et ça qui vous
intéressent explorer et à ce cheminement
qui a été ordonnée tranquille calme ce
cas la personne c'est la sexualité mais
aussi de la relation humaine et
relationnelle sont compliquées des
rumeurs sans complexe ont raté leur avec
le livre de richard malka parce que on
voit un peu quand même que l'humanité
complexe il faut surtout pas penser que
ce convoi l'apparence et la vérité là
derrière chaque visa usage il ya un
mystère et qu'on ne fait pas de mystère
il y a la peur et sachez vous voulez
vous l'ancré dans une réalité très
visuel parce que une fille peut être un
garçon inversement ils nombreux sont les
histoires qui finalement sous forme de
contes ou de l'italie sur sur le trans
tel retournement sur le détournement
d'une identité qu'elle soit sexuelle
culturel au social c'est ça ces
détournements c'est le père qui a voulu
détourner de cette cette fille de son
destin et voilà ce qui se passe après la
notion destin est importante chez vous
c'est le fatalité aussi vous proposer
des récits ou des acomptes la fatalité
la natalité peut être lourde de malheur
quand on quand on y croit
juste un an la souabe la responsabilité
de chaque être de est présent dans tout
ce qu'il fait et d'ailleurs dans l'islam
il est tout tandis que l'être est
responsable de ce qu'il fait ce qu'il
dit pas devant les hommes et devant dieu
aujourd'hui ce qui se passe c'est que
l'on veut nous faire croire que
le musulman est responsable devant ses
voisins devant ses professeurs ou devant
ses parents non il est responsable
devant dieu et ça c'est intéressant
qu'il croit que je crois pas c'est une
autre histoire mais tout tout tout tout
tout le malheur d'actuels de
détournement du cela vient du fait que
des gens veulent nous imposer
comment vivre de cette religion nous
impose et comment ces gens va tous les
intégrer tous les toutous ces
terroristes de la pensée ou même de
l'action qu'il faut qu'il prenne cette
religion et la transforme pour un dogme
et ils se prennent pour dieu
or c'est une religion de liberté où
chacun est responsable ce qu'il fait et
n'a de compte à rendre à personne si ce
n'est à son dieu n'a pas on n'a pas à
les écouter de les lui même du coin pour
lui dirai ce que je peux faire simple
nous contacter petit je me souviens
quand on a envoyé nos copains et se
confesser les copains chrétiens entre
c'est très bizarre comment tu vas parler
un même bonhomme comme toi de ce que tu
fais en cachette c'est n'est pas là il
faut pas les attendus c'est un peu comme
ça il faut pas qu'ils d'intermédiaire
entre dieu et soit site alors ça ça pose
un autre problème c'est que comme il n'y
a pas d'intermédiaire entre le croyant
est son dieu il n'y a pas en islam
sunnite de hiérarchie a pas de papier
pas d'imam n'y a rien c'est pour ça
qu'on n'arrive pas en france à avoir
quelqu'un qui représente la communauté
musulmane
on est un problème c'est qu'on peut la
fabriquer un représentant mais encore
faut aussi qu'il soit choisi par toutes
les tendances de la religion musulmane
en france parce qu'il n'ya pas que
l'intérêt du sionisme est plutôt
tendance ce qui est très difficile
est ce que les responsables politiques
n'arrivent pas à comprendre et vous vous
considérez comme un écrivain musulmans
non je suis un écrivain ma culture
religieuse ne regarde que moi et je ne
parle jamais un jour quelqu'un m'avait
dit est ce que tu crois que ça te
regarde pas c'est privé je suis laïc
absolument laïque est ce que je crois au
ne crois pas ne me regardent comme moi
et je ne parlerai jamais
c'était donc vous distinguer ce que vous
écrivez le sujet devant suivre mais qui
sont pourtant ancrée dans l'est
gestion de culture musulmane donc c'est
ancré dans une réalité que je que je
veux bien sûr que je lis que je vis et
que j'assume je mets évidemment mais
même les personnages sansan ancré dans
cette réalité qui est bien sûr
religieuses souvent qui est social et
tout est et c'est normal normal que
j'utilise cette religion comme cadre
dans lequel se passe et c'est normal que
de base en date dans la nuit sacrée
il a une critiques très acerbes des de
la manière dont certains cultivent
l'islam déjà à l'époque à plus de 30 ans
20 81 87 feuille des temps
ce qui au maroc doit susciter un certain
trouble non à l'époque j'avais des
problèmes avec des gens rient qui
comprenait pas parce que je rêvais des
scènes assez explicite et puis alors ce
qui est amusant c'est mais tous mes
livres sont traduits en arabe mais c'est
sacré en français oui je suis toujours
en france et jamais qui attend notre
langue et mai mais ils sont traduits en
arabe mais après ils sont piratés
systématiquement au liban et en syrie et
la syrie fait un petit arrangement
elle coupe tout ce qui ne l'a n'aime pas
dans un livre par exemple de toutes les
saints sexuelles assène d'euros du jeune
pousse à se couper d'un potentiel man le
super à thème et je suis très haut dans
la série de l'époque pas maintenant
maintenant ils sont en train de battre
en train de massacrer tranquillement son
peuple mais vous êtes vous dit vous je
suis trahi
vous avez un rapport à la langue qui est
double aussi et vous dites qu est
toujours une forme d'immigration quand
on écrit on va dans un autre territoire
dans un autre pays qui est celui de
l'écriture doit toujours prendre ses
distances par rapport aux pays d'où on
vient même si en a plusieurs mois la
langue arabe se présente à moi à chaque
fois que j'écris elle est là elle est
présente le mais vous choisissez le
français oui mais mais régulier des
français à ma façon et j'ai des crises
électrique le plus correctement possible
mais j'essaie aussi de le démettre un
peu des pis des pistes arabe et marocain
surtout ce qui donne un petit peu de
deux particularités ça ce que j'écris
parler des pistes d'aller de l'écriture
comme si c'était un plat et on sent chez
vous cette ce plaisir d'écrire qui
pourtant n'est jamais complètement
déconnecté d'une forme quand même
d'engagement si ce n'est politique du
moins du moins sociétal qui est très
fort encore plus dans votre dernier
livre la punition oui mais ça c'est
normal d'être engagés on peut pas être
neutre ni n'importe quelle société
surtout quand on est le cas du maroc on
peut pas rester indifférent et et en
france non plus vous avez écrit le
racisme expliqué à ma fille notamment
les ouvrages la wii semble très
pédagogique c'est très utile c'était
l'espagne l'unité reste un livre
important que et dernièrement alors
justement parler des mots j'ai participé
à un ouvrage qui va paraître mois de mai
sur les migrants et moi j'ai choisi de
raconter une histoire drôle et si les
mots tous les mots d'origine étrangère
qui vont quitter lectionnaire parce que
la politique actuelle du gouvernement ne
veut plus de ces étrangers dans qu'ils
foutent le camp et voilà la france est
bloqué parce qu'on peut plus parler on
peut plus discuter et bars cran est très
embêté parce qu'ici même si distrib plus
les faire parce que il lui manque
tellement de mots qui vient de l'arabe
ou du pouls du l'iranien ou du chinois
enfin peu importe
et tous les mondes étrangers ils ont ils
sont fait la malle son parti est plus
dictionnaire plein de trous dedans il se
trouvait un petit peur dans une
situation et sait plus comment parler
dit faites quelque chose faites les
revenir et les revenir et l'autre vidéo
me demande des visas
enfin bon j'ai traité ce sujet de
l'immigration d'une manière un peu drôle
parce que j'en avais marre des plus le
temps que je parle de ce sujet de dû
dire à la france et de recommander à ce
pays de rester fidèle à ses traditions
tradition d'asile de respect de l'autre
de respecter les droits des autres et de
fresnes une terre d'asile n'atteint un
terreau qui accueille non pas qu'ils qui
rejette sa la france que j'aime la
france qui m'a accueilli qui accueille
beaucoup tellement de gens vous pensez
qu'aujourd'hui elle devrait en
accueillir plus il devra en tout cas
avant une politique plus plus généreuse
et plus et plus humaine
je ne s'agit pas comme disait une rocade
la guerre la misère du voilà et mais il
faut voir ça part comme l'a fait la
suite de la phrase mais en même temps il
faut avoir une politique il faut pas
penser par rapport au front national
faut pas penser par rapport à l'extrême
droite vous pensé par rapport au bien de
la france la france
voilà le mal est là et là elle a
récupéré un million trois cent mille
réfugiés la plupart sont des réfugiés
syriens y est inquiet ils sont tous
logés ils apprennent l'allemand leurs
enfants sont dans les écoles allemandes
et ça fera des petits allemands qui vont
faire plein d'enfants à l'allemagne elle
n'a pas fait ça pas fait discret
allemagne la france je pense qu'elle
peut être généreuse ne dit pas comment
je ne je n'ai pas le dossier soit mais
mais mais ils doivent à l'intention
d'une certaine générosité en faisant
faisant une terre d'accueil
et puis penser le problème de la limite
des migrations de en allant plutôt
empêcher que certains pays du sud ou
d'afrique du sud à rien de laisser
partir la leur leurs cours de leurs
citoyens
il faut que qu'on fasse tout pour que
ces pays qui sont riches du nigeria est
riche
le gabon est très riche mais cet argent
nous ne fonctionne pas bien et au lieu
d'investir et d'obliger ces états de
demain une politique qui donne du
travail aux gens on laisse faire et les
gens viennent parce qu'ils fuient la
misère et la pauvreté
le problème est de savoir comment
statuer de manière
législatives sur ces problèmes là on en
arrive aux problèmes de la loi que vous
traitez dans votre livre la punition
puisque vous êtes soumis à une loi qui
vous paraît absolument injuste s'impose
à vous comme quelque chose de tyrannique
quasiment la punition c'est le moose
c'est pas une loi mais dix ans c'est une
décision qui a été prise par des
militaires parce qu'il fallait dès qu'on
rentrait dans le camp dit qu'on est
rentré il fallait nous humilier la
première humiliation que je re se
passait à l'époque j'avais des cheveux
longs c'était de nous tendre comme les
comme des moutons de nous enlever ses
cheveux de nous donner des habits
militaires horrible et nous traiter
comme des animaux qui est s'était égaré
qu'il fallait remettre sur le droit
chemin
le droit chemin chez eux c'était une
vraie dictature
on va continuer cette discussion dans un
instant avec l'avocat richard malka qui
vient de publier un roman tyrannie
justement à partir de cette question de
la loi est ce que la loi ne serait pas
par essence tyrannique ou est-ce qu'au
contraire la vocation à protéger les
gens je vous propose avant d'accueillir
richard malka d'écouté l'intervention de
léo ferré léo ferré qui vous propose
cette définition de l'anarchie c'est à
dire ce qu'ils considèrent que la loi
est toujours peut-être un obstacle ali
mehdi phase i/ii chante la marche est
encore faut-il la vie voici c'est très
difficile de vivre la marche et on les
écoute
oui léo ferré les gens ont peur de ce
mot anarchiste pourtant vous avez
l'anarchie c'est bien triste il y fait
seul il y fait froid et d'autre part
qu'est ce que ça veut dire anarchie ça
veut dire la négation de l'autorité moi
je n'ai pas encore rencontré un homme
qui médit en face je veux absolument
obéir à quelqu'un ou à quelque chose je
veux définitivement être une lavette
vous comprenez on imagine un anarchiste
avec la la panoplie de ravachol cet
idiot voilà et puis ça sert à rien ce
que je dis pas ce que brandir a toujours
l'anarchie commun
comme un quelqu'un qui est en dehors du
coup en dehors du temps pourtant dieu
sait si je ne suis ni en dehors du coup
ni en dehors du temps c'était léo ferré
en mars 1965 dans l'émission discorama
présenté par la merveilleuse denise les
airs sur le rtf
bonjour richard malka un jours merci
nous avoir rejoints vous avez entendu
léo ferré vous pensez alors je pose la
question à l'avocat que vous êtes est ce
que la loi est toujours tyrannique dont
je pense le contraire
vous savez ce que disait cicéron à ce
sujet pour moi c'est un des plus grands
génies de l'humanité pour lui le peuple
était ce qu'il y avait de plus odieux en
termes de tyrannie c'était une bête
féroce
s'ils n'étaient tenus dans le lien
commun qui est la loi
la loi fait la démocratie autant que la
démocratie fait la loi sans loi
vous avez une forte chance de tomber
dans la tyrannie mais il doit peut-être
injuste
une loi peut-être injuste mais dans une
démocratie si elle est injuste vous
n'êtes pas d'accord on l'a changé cinq
ans plus tard il ya des lois que je
n'aime pas mais je les respecte les lois
sont restrictives de liberté
les lois qui vous interdise de consommer
des stupéfiants de rouler à 200 à
l'heure qui interviennent en matière de
procréation sont toujours grignan que
les libertés mais c'est le lien commun
qui nous unit et si il est si elles vont
trop loin si elles grignotent rôle et
libertés si le peuple n'est pas content
il peut en changer parce qu'il est dans
une démocratie qui est basée sur la loi
et ben c'est d'ailleurs un ballon 80 ans
dans l'article 10 de la création de
raglan il est dit de ne pas troubler
l'ordre public établi par la loi c'est
la loi qui établit l'ordre
c'est pas le contraire alors richard
malka vous êtes avocat je les dis vous à
la différente tahar ben jelloun que vous
connaissez votre année de naissance
on n'a pas vu de la révéler en tout cas
oui mais je connais pas celle de mon
père qui était marocain au c'est vrai
absolument absolue et pire encore
vous avez ouvert votre votre premier
cabinet en 1999 vous avez plaidé au
moment du procès des caricatures de
mahomet tôt aux côtés de charlie hebdo
pour la sphère de la crèche baby loup
pour l' affaire dsk pour de nombreuses
grandes affaires juridiques vous est
aussi l'auteur de bande dessinée de
science-fiction souvent dystopique on
prévoit voilà dans un futur proche ou
lointain que le pire va arriver et vous
faites vous publiez tyrannie qui votre
premier roman et qui met en scène un
procès donc on sent le plaisir de
l'avocat à décrire les coulisses d'un
procès un procès un procès assez
atypique on se demande si vous faites le
procès de la france où d'un pays
imaginaire dont il est question dans ce
dans ce livre qu'en est il d'abord mon
souci c'était de faire rentrer le
lecteur au centre d'une salle d'audience
parce que je ne connais rien qui soit
plus intense papa le théâtre pàp le
cinéma même pas la littérature que ce
qui se passe dans ce théâtre du réel qui
est une salle d'audience où la vie de
gens se jouent pour de vrai et je ne
connais rien d'équivalent en termes de
dramaturgie d'un conte d'essence des
combats les blocs de là c'est la guerre
et mais c'est la guerre avec un vrai
enjeu humain donc je voulais placer de
lecteurs à la place des jurés des juges
des avocats des greffières le faire
participer à cette aventure romanesque
qu'est un procès et puis bah il n'est
pas interdit de réfléchir sur son temps
c'est ce que j'aime dans les romans aux
6,7 profondeur que donne la réflexion
politique donc j'ai fait un lien entre
ce procès qui se déroule sur 25 jours
dans à la cour d'assises de paris est
une tyrannie qui s'installe dans un pays
indéterminé qui peut être n'importe quel
pays et il s'appelle astra si absolument
clean ans de celui qui dirige isidora
l'afrique qui invente une nouveau
totalitarisme alors j'ai essayé de
réfléchir sur les totalitarismes
d'hyères aux communistes sur les
totalitarismes d'aujourd'hui en tout cas
en germe l'islamisme radical
éventuellement pour inventer celui de
demain
aujourd'hui la turquie d'aujourd'hui et
y en a d'autres pour réfléchir à ce que
pourrait être
le totalitarisme de demain est le point
d'ancrage à travers ce procès est
particulièrement réussie justement parce
que non seulement pour le lecteur c'est
absolument haletant on vit au jour le
jour
le déroulé d'un procès mais on se
demande en fait il ya aussi beaucoup de
retournements et un peu c'est un peu un
roman policier en a disons le en deux
mots il ya ce personnage principal qui
s'appelle rappel constant qui est avocat
et qui doit défendre hausse karima qui
lui est jugé à paris pour le meurtre
d'un diplomate de l'ambassade d'astra si
le pays de l'ue les biens ou donc ce
régime tyrannique d'ailleurs astra si ça
ressemble à autarcie un peu non non non
pas dans mon esprit ce nom à cet art si
quand même ans tidiane on n'entend pas
instruits de creed c'était plutôt seul
et on va c'est donc des liens vont se
créer il ya forcément des personnages
féminins c'est qu'il ya 13 ans bah oui
aux violences et voilà qui est qui et
qui est vraiment très présente et c'est
l'occasion pour vous donc de dresser le
portrait de ce pays qu'est la star silas
tracy pardon ce pays un peu un peu
étrange qui a deux caractéristiques la
première c'est que la devise c'est pas
liberté égalité fraternité mais
transparence vertus humilité
oui c'est très effrayant c'est l'arrêté
maclure à la voie là et que tous les
jeunes âgés de 14 à 18 ans doivent
porter un cash visage hommes comme
femmes une métaphore du voile ou pas
seulement c'est une métaphore du voile
que toutes les religions etc d'apposer
sur les libertés individuelles
les religions veulent limiter aimé
liberté ma liberté de me vêtir comme je
veux de manger comme je veux d'avoir la
sexualité que je veux donc c'est une
métaphore en réalité de tous les
dogmatismes what is ou de la religion
les religions oui une tendance à devenir
dogmatique et bien sûr mais pas de
plaisanteries avec la religion n'est pas
d'humour dans la religion
ça dépend des religions n'ont aucune ne
supporte l'humour ni le rire ça c'est la
pire des deux pire des insultes de rire
quoi que ce soit on a reçu il ya pas
longtemps le rabbin delphine horvilleur
qui disait qu'au contraire elle aimait
commencer toutes les interventions par
une blague et que l'humeur de tel mythe
j'ai dû dire ça c'est pas très drôle
c'est très sérieux
c'est reda c'est dramatique et tragique
le tous les textes religieux sont
tragiques
on parle de l'un de l'enfer et de la rue
du paradis on parle de pêcher en pas des
vertus reparlera de la punition
justement on est punis si on ne sait pas
bien conduit dans la vie non mais
justement c'est là je fais le parallèle
avec mon métier d'avocat tard a raison
il ya assez peu d'humour dans les
religions et les religions en tout cas
quand elles sont interprétées de manière
un peu radical ne supporte pas l'humour
et on retombe sur les caricatures de
malal sur la question du blasphème et du
rire qui est insupportable alors que ses
larmes des démocrates
donc c'est vrai l'avocat de charlie
hebdo au moment de l' affaire des
caricatures de mahomet oui et donc
c'était là c'était il fallait plaidé en
faveur de l'humour absolue qui est
insupportable c'est vrai qu'on a
rarement vu des talibans
faire de l'humour quelque sorte être les
religions d'ailleurs quels que soient
les religions le dogmatisme ne supporte
pas la remise en cause
la distance à soi que suppose l'humour
alors vous affirmez dans votre dans
votre roman richard malka iai qui est
une chose que l'homme préfère à la
liberté c'est l'esclavagé c'est
l'esclave est alors j'ai pas moi qui le
dit c'est dostoïevski pour le coup je le
dément mais oui et ça c'est une
constante de l'humanité c'est très
compliqué d'être libres d'être seul sous
le ciel responsables se veut être
responsable de ne pas avoir de cadres de
ne pas qu'on ne vous disent pas ce que
vous devez faire là où vous devez vous
orienter c'est très rassurant d'avoir
des règles c'est très rassurant que l'on
vous dise comment vous comporter quelle
est la bonne sexualité qu'elle est la
mauvaise où vous devez aller à quoi vous
devez croire pour aller dans l'au delà
cc c'est très compliqué de ce seul fait
d'être libre mais est-ce que c'est pas
là où la loi peut justement parfois se
substituer au libre arbitre quand les
lois nous peuvent nous protéger mais
parfois elles peuvent aussi on peut s'en
remettre aux lois ce qu'ils pensent de
ce qui dispense de réfléchir par son ami
david par semaine bien sûr mais dans une
démocratie les lois ont un contrecoup
vraiment toujours des contre-pouvoirs
alors il ya le contrôle du conseil
constitutionnel et puis à la presse
et puis il ya un parlement et puis un
pouvoir exécutif dans une dans un
pouvoir totalitaire
alors un à vingt ans cartographier 2 le
stalinisme et le nazisme il y en a il y
en a il y en a un peu plus mais dans un
pouvoir totalitaire
vous n'avez pas de contre-pouvoirs vous
n'avez qu'un seul pouvoir
c'est ce qui manquait justement à nant
le gouvernement marocain moment vous
avez été enfermé à tahar ben jelloun est
positif à une vindicte et urs était un
régime mais qui avait percuté qui était
répressif et qui faisait plus confiance
à l'armée à la police qu'on partis
politiques qui proposait une autre façon
de gouverner le maroc
c'était les années 60 c'était juste
après la disparition de mehdi ben barka
donc c'est in il y avait une tension
dans le pays et n'importe quelle
manifestation était perçu comme un
danger pour le régime et vous parleriez
la tyrannie ou pas chers amis où il veut
dire aller dans la mesure où n'étaient
pas libres de nous exprimer de parler
moi je me souviens mon père baisser la
voix à l'intérieur de la maison quand
ils devaient critiqué le régime jeudi
mais enfin on est entre nous on peut
annoncer un jeu taillé faut pas donc on
était de dire encore une fois
heureusement le maroc d'aujourd'hui n'a
strictement plus rien à voir avec cette
période horrible qu'on appelait les
années de plomb qui en a vu d'autres
alors moi c'était rien même puni société
c'était du pipi de chat par rapport à ce
qui était atteint sa maturité qui sont
morts par rapport à un des poètes comme
avec l'habit qui a passé huit ans et vit
uniquement pour ses idées et et d'autres
reka et d'autres pour être qu'ils ont
été en prison pour leurs idées
uniquement n'avait rien fait
d'extraordinaire savez penser autrement
penser contre le régime
donc tout ça pour excuser ce que j'ai
adoré dans ce livre parce qu'il est tard
avec beaucoup d'humilité dit qu'il
s'était pas grand chose de ce qu'il a
vécu mais enfin c'était quand même un
long calvaire
c'est
et qu'au travers de son cas il démonte
quelque chose d'universel qui est que
l'autorisent les régimes autoritaires la
tyrannie et la dictature
ça commence toujours par ce qu'il ya
dans mon livre c'est à dire des grands
principes des envolées lyriques de l'
enthousiasme y compris des peuples parce
que ça s'installe pas s'il n'y a pas une
partie du peuple significative qui suit
et puis ça finit toujours comme il le
démontre dans l'absurdité la plus totale
c'est à dire que il est dans dans son
camp militaire et puis un jour on lui
demande avec ses camarades allaient
construire un mur un kilomètre et il
porte des pires toute la journée pendant
plusieurs jours ils savent pas pourquoi
puis le lendemain leur demande de
déconstruire le mur ils savent pas non
plus pourquoi est par ailleurs ils
doivent coût de leur poche de pantalon
parce que faut avoir froid ça sinon on
est une femme let
c'est l'expression que vous utilisez
donc on vous demande des choses on sait
pas pourquoi c'est totalement absurde
on finit dans la médiocrité et dans
l'aberration là c'est l'absurdité qui
était sur la surdité est alors alors que
c'est au départ c'est je raconte cette
histoire
et puis l'histoire va me rejoindre
l'histoire l'histoire la grande avec un
grand h c'est à dire que c'est ces
officiers et sous-officiers qui nous ont
maltraité pendant deux ans ce sont
ceux-là mêmes qui vont faire le premier
coup d'état contre center en 71 lors de
son anniversaire à serez apte et qui
vont pénétrer le la fête et massacrer
tout le monde se sent que ces gens là
qui devait les pu dire qu'ils vont se
retourner contre le roi et vouloir
l'assassiner extraordinaire alors là du
coup je me dis c'est horrible j'ai vécu
ça ils voient et quand j'écoutais la
radio pendant le déroulement du coup
d'état j'avais la trouille de ma vie
parce que si jamais il réussissait elle
était foutu on aurait fait une série ou
un en irak en libye comme aujourd'hui
c'est à dire un chaos total
m votre position d'avocats richard malka
là c'est intéressant parce que vous êtes
votre métier de défendre d'autres
personnes
dans votre roman vous mettez en scène
aussi l'avocat qui va défendre la
tyrannie et douarche non est ce que vous
auriez pu défendre est ce que vous
auriez pu être edwards sur lesquels les
pauses que les causes pour les combats à
défendre or on n'est pas toujours du
côté du bien ce dernier qu'on parle de
l'ald une forme qu'on défend à quelqu'un
la loi est la loi mais quand on me parle
du bien moi je me méfie toujours jeu
cela c est le bien à la pureté bien et à
l'utilité et la vertu et c'est le sens
de votre roman et c'est que sans en
dévoiler les ressorts de la danse ou le
bien et puis rien et
blanc ou noir peut-être nos vestes mais
ça et personne n'est totalement ange ou
démon
c'est oui c'est mais après effectivement
on choisit ses causes
non je n'aurais pas j'aurais
probablement pas accepté de défendre
celle que défend edouard shawn ans dans
ce livre mais voilà ça c'est une
question de conscience de chacun et pour
autant
et pour autant on est jeune on a tout à
fait le droit de défendre ce qu'il
pensait être le bien c'est à dire la
tyrannie parce que la tyrannie ne se
présente pas comme une tyrannie
le prêt la tyrannie toujours se présente
comme une avancée pour l'humanité elle
avance sous l'étendard du bien justement
de l'autorité retrouver de l'ordre de
l'égalité 2-2 l'écologie 2
voilà on vous dit jamais et
ça va être catastrophique vous retirer
vos libertés
vous allez tous vivre en prison
d'ailleurs le tyran est élu comme hitler
a été élu comme erdogan a été élu comme
dans d'autres domaines
prince qui n'est pas un tyran ni un
dictateur était lui aussi c'est un
populiste donc oui le peuple peut créer
bien sûr dans ce livre c'est de montrer
combien le peuple est vraiment le plus
vrai tyrannique la vraie tyrannie vient
du peuple et c'est on a vu tellement
d'exemples de peuples suivre des fous
furieux et d'ailleurs tu parles de trump
grimpe et lille il représente une
amérique réel qui existe c'est pas c'est
pas farfelue il farfelue il est il est
tout ce qu'on peut dire époux mais aussi
il est il oui il est le représentant
d'une d'une amérique qui existe qui
assistent qui et haineuse qui est
violente qui est meurtrière il la
représente
et ce qui est formidable c'est de voir
comment on peut explorer c'est travers
la humain alors qu'ils sont effrayants
quand ce sont ceux de personnalités
politiques qui dirigent des pays des
pays puissants mais littérairement cccc
vraiment c'est là où c'est formidable
richard malka ont soit votre votre
jouissance à explorer justement un
avocat qui défend d'autres causes que
les vôtres et il ya peut-être un peu une
sorte de fantasme dans la littérature
pas votre recours à la littérature doit
servir au cias si vous n'auriez pas
écrit mais pour moi le personnage le
plus fascinant c'est pas un des deux
avocats saisis de race tri c'est à dire
le client mais parce que
il ya aussi un philosophe un derrière
quel c'est intéressant dans ce roman
daniel armand ski oui alors ça c'est un
autre volet mais au travers de ce tyran
en réalité j'interroge nous mêmes
cette part de tyrannie on l'a tous au
fond nous en réalité ces tyrans de sont
l'expression que de ce que qu'ils
existent on nous cette volonté de pureté
cette volonté d'être meilleur et donc
exclure le mal et c'est ce que je
raconte d'enfin j'aime bien une petite
histoire qui est que quand athènes
banny dione dionysos de la cité parce
que c'est dieu du vin parce qu'on veut
créer une société meilleure amie il
revient toujours sous forme de sparte
quand on essaie c'est à dire d'une
société autoritaire quand on essaie
d'exclure le mal le démon qui est en
nous plutôt que de le domestique et de
le regarder en face éventuellement de le
poser dans des livres on a finit
toujours par créer un goulag donc le
vrai danger c'est le règne du bien c'est
la tyrannie du bien enfin bah oui oui
d'accord mou tout court
c'est la même chose mais la tyrannie je
présente pas telle qu'elle est et ce
qu'on a masqué avec des mots qui font
plaisir aux gens les expressions toutes
faites
on trouve ça partout non là on n'a que
ça en amérique latine dans les années 70
on le voit aujourd'hui notamment en
turquie où je suis très inquiet parce
que quand même est un écrivain qui a été
condamné à perpétuité pour avoir écrit
il n'a tué personne
et puis aujourd'hui il ya des
journalistes qui sont condamnés sans
procès dans le procès tant qu'on ne
comprend pas comment aujourd'hui encore
dans un pays qui aurait pu faire partie
de l'europe
on est en train de condamner des gens
pour leurs idées leurs pensées koné à
perpétuité mais c'est la folie et pour
leurs idées leurs pensées pour le fait
même d'être en train d'écrire
oui qu'est l'écriture elle-même et à la
grèce bien sûr mais ça c'est souffrir
d'ailleurs on aurait dû on aurait dû
faire entrer la turquie en europe
n'aurait dû parce que là elle serait
dans un cadre où la démocratie existe où
on peut pas faire n'importe quoi
même si la pologne aujourd'hui la
hongrie nous trahissent même ml quand
même mais je pense que avoir l'europe la
turquie en europe ont été à bien pour
les turcs et aussi pour les européens
mais à reste à savoir si on peut opposer
l'occident d'un côté les autres pays de
l'autre et si le fait de faire venir
tout le monde en occident en europe
résoudrait les problèmes il ya toujours
cette espèce de manichéisme d'ailleurs
ces présents dans votre livre aussi même
justement de manière romanesque entre
chez nous et c'est ailleurs qu'il
n'existe pas et où le pire pourrait
advenir
oui c'est pour ça que j'ai tenu à ne pas
identifier
le pays qui sont qui devenait il changer
de nom étudié venelles à ses proches
qu'il est partout il est partout et
c'est pour ça que ça fonctionne très
bien
pourquoi avoir pour ce reste il a choisi
la forme romanesque que je dis vous avez
est l'auteur de plusieurs bandes
dessinées qui elle aussi quand même
mettre en scène une façon de voir le
pire qui sont je disais des dystopies
c'est-à-dire linverse d'une utopie voilà
comment le pire pourrait arriver
ailleurs et dans pas si longtemps et là
le besoin de deux romans c'est ça ba a
eu alors on pose effectivement souvent
cette question vous savez depuis que ma
plus tendre enfance je me raconte des
histoires à moi même alors ensuite suis
devenu avocat j'ai découvert des
milliers d'histoires que j'étais chargé
de raconter mais ce n'était pas mes
histoires
ensuite j'avais besoin de raconter mes
histoires donc les ai écrites sous forme
de bande dessinée mais il ya quand même
quelques uns le dessinateur qui est un
filtre il ya l'image qui contraint sanaa
au bout du compte je n'étais pas seul à
raconter ces histoires ce livre où là on
est seul quand on écrit la crypte pour
moi parce que moi je viens c'est un
aboutissement jiji
j'aime la bd comme ça mais je n'arrive
pas à lire donc aime beaucoup le sens
commun qui dise pas les bd dont il a
écrit un roman
voilà c'est interdit absolu mais bon
voilà c'était une sorte d'aboutissement
d'un chemin qui consiste toujours à
raconter des histoires et là j'avais
besoin de la profondeur d'un roman pour
raconter celle là moi j'encourage pas
malherbe bande dessinée parce qu'elles
sont elles sont versées moi aussi il
s'empare alors de cicéron pulsions
section financière vous avez écrit sur
voilà beaucoup beaucoup de temps
beaucoup d'univers différents et le
roman n'est en rien incompatible
là je reviendrai à la bande dessinée à
la fin qui terrible en bande dessinée
c'est difficile en fait impossible alors
j'imagine que dans les livres que vous
avez apporté tahar ben jelloun il n'y a
pas de bandes dessinées j'aurais bien
compris je vous ai demandé comme à
chaque émission en devenir avec vos
trois livres de chevet alors dites nous
quel laquelle tout me dit que vous avez
choisi don quichotte de la manche
ça c'est le papa de toute la littérature
moderne c'est cervantes qui a créé le
roman moderne et d'une modernité absolue
dans l'écriture et dans la construction
du texte c'est fabuleux c'est magnifique
c'est je suis fou de lire et relire tout
le temps c'est du romanesque à l'état
pur salaires déjà traité mais imaginez
tout est inventé
et tout est incroyable et tout est
croyable j'ai formé dame alors jean
genet le funambule vous en avait parlé
vous avez dit qu'ils étaient présents
lors de votre soutenance de thèse et un
ami j'ai un ami j'ai écrit un livre sur
lui s'appelle jean genet le menteur
sublime pour expliquer un peu cette
toute relation mais sans texte le
funambule est un texte sublime parce que
il est il réellement d'une très grande
poésie et qui vient de très loin ça
vient de sa relation tragique avec
abdallah a quitté sans l'amour de sa vie
et qui va se suicider et parce que il va
tomber un jour du film et ne supportant
pas de ne plus monter sur le fil il va
se supprimer et il va d'ailleurs on va
trouver dans autour de lui il va se
pendre
on va trouver plein de textes de jean
genet déchiré experts bon c'est une
histoire atroce mais le texte est
magnifique mais ensuite je parle de la
poésie de mahmoud darwish qui nous a
malheureusement quittés très jeune très
grand poète il n'est pas pour être parce
qu'ils les palestiniens mais je crois le
fait d'être palestinien
le fait de vivre un drame une tragédie
quotidienne a fait de lui un grand poète
d'une valeur universelle et
et quand il parle de sa terre quand il
parle de ça sa maison imaginaire
c'est ça parle à toute l'humanité qui
souffrent aujourd'hui ne pas avoir une
paire ne pas avoir une maison ne pas
avoir un lieu pour vivre et c'était l'un
des plus grands poètes john rabe qui
traduit dans plusieurs langues blythe
traduit par il est 100 bars d'enchères
actes sud la trace du papillon 1 1 du
texte passionnant qui brasse des
papillons à lire donc il reste trois
jours encore à 7
au printemps des poètes vous savez c'est
en ce moment ah oui je trouve que c'est
bien le printemps des prêtres dit bien
sûr tout ce qui peut faire lire les gens
tout ce qui peut amener la poésie entre
les mains ddd du des jeunes et des moins
jeunes c'est formidable il faut le faire
et moi j'appuie absolument ce printemps
des poètes et c'est une méchante mans
richard malka ce contrôle de la poésie
dans vos livres de chevet par contre je
fis je me classe sur la dernière page il
ya dans votre livre
alors moi je vais peut-être commencer
par barjavel lorsque c'est le précurseur
de la science fiction française et c'est
un joueur qui m'a beaucoup influencé en
fait petit j'avais le droit de lire un
roman de science fiction à chaque fois
que je lisais un roman classique ce qui
fait que j'ai beaucoup lu des romans
classiques pour avoir ce droit là c'est
un livre magnifiquement écrit c'est une
histoire d'amour comme on les aime qui
va au delà de la mort c'est une version
science fiction de tristan et iseult
voilà c'est celui-ci en particulier la
nuit des temps alors la nuit des temps
mais pour moi ça regroupe tout tout le
genre de la science-fiction et la nuit
des temps c'est le premier roman de
barjavel que j'ai lu avant de lire tous
les autres stefan zweig dans un genre
très différent parce que basse et celles
à l'élégance de l'écriture la finesse de
la description des émotions des
sentiments
c'est pour moi un modèle d'écriture
celui-là est moins connu que les autres
c'est d'abord ce sont des nouvelles
c'est un genre qui n'a pas beaucoup de
succès en chandelier enterrés alors le
chandelier intéressé l'histoire c'est un
peu le indiana jones de stefan zweig
c'est l'histoire du chandelier du temple
qui emmenée par les romains puis pris
par les vandales lors du sac de rome
puis qui finit à b à byzance et puis il
ya un groupe de vieux juif parce que
c'est l'objet le plus sacré pour eux qui
part à la recherche de ce chandelier sur
des décennies et des décennies on les
suit dans cette quête
et c'est une nouvelle c'est une nouvelle
merveilleuse et puis pas le dernier à
part évidemment le tahar benjelloun
c'est l'homme qui rit de hugo parce
qu'alors là pour moi tu parlais de
cervantès mois pour moi c'est vraiment
l'horreur aujourd hui donc vous vous
conseille quand même de lire hugo oui
parce que parce que c'est une liste
c'est un roman d'une ampleur incroyable
assez fantasmagorique où on sait plus
très bien qui sont les les êtres humains
les animaux il ya une espèce de
de confusion entre les deux et puis vous
avez un fond très politique et c'est ce
que j'aime
il critique de l'aristocratie de la
bourgeoisie des inégalités sociales qui
donne de l'ampleur une ampleur
incroyable
au delà de l'écriture évidemment
j'aurais pu aussi choisir évidemment le
dernier jour d'un condamné à mort comme
avocat vous visez vous les misérables
mari l'amant dans une finition
extraordinaire j'ai la pléiade avec
toute une chronologie parce qu'il y
avait avant santelli misère d'autant que
la mine les médias et on raconte que les
étapes de cette écriture ce livre
universel qui voulait un livre universel
il l'a fait il a réussi oui il allait
vers les agences livre aussi on va vers
l'universel victor hugo nous terminerons
cette émission merci à tous les deux
d'être venu nous parler de la
littérature mais c'était le but ce
formidable et on va se quitter avec une
voix on a on a entendu sa voix tout à
l'heure d'ailleurs vous le citez dans
votre livre la finition tahar ben
jelloun
c'était un moment voilà vous voulez voir
avatar au cinéma a finalement diffusé un
claude lelouch alors vous êtes
complètement désespéré vous pensé à
certains chanteurs dont léo ferré savoie
qui dieu ni maître
avec un peu
ministère de ce prêtre
alors faites
[Musique]
quina
peut-être
ni les yeux
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
il m
c'était livrez vous avec le concours du
centre national du livre
[Musique]